Gagner près de 10 000€ par seconde vous intéresse ?
Bonjour, mon nom est Stéphane
Je vais vous montrer une technique pour gagner près de 10 000 € par seconde
Sans bouger de chez vous, sans même sortir de votre lit
Sans même vous réveiller, sans même en avoir conscience
Cette technique est basée sur une méthode qu'utilise les traders américains aussi appelé "American Traders"
Certains peuvent penser que cela est fastidieux et complexe, pourtant c'est très simple
Regardez, la méthode consiste à... à parier, en fait, sur des courbes...
Bon, je sais plus exactement , mais pourtant c'est très simple
La preuve, certaines personnes ont véritablement adopté cette technique
Et en sont aujourd'hui très heureux
Grâce a cette méthode, j'ai pu gagner plus de 10 000€ par minute
Seconde !
Par seconde sans sortir de chez moi.
C'est bon Stéphane, je peux y aller, j'ai dit la phrase. Non non c'est bon j'y vais maintenant.
ATTENDS (coup de feu)
Ça marche véritablement !!!
Vous n’êtes pas convaincu, laissez moi vous le prouver avec mon propre argent
Je mise par exemple 5€ sur une valeur de bourse montante au postulat aléatoire
Alors on va maintenant mettre 5€
Alors, ça dépend... peut être que c'est pas le bon jour
(Rire)
Bon, ça marche souvent en tout cas
Cette technique fonctionne en 4 étapes vraiment très simples, "easy etape"
Connectez-vous a notre site internet : énorme arnaque-on se fout littéralement de votre gueule.argent
Entrez vos coordonnées bancaires ensuite... c'est tout
Voila attendez. Faites vous un café, mettez vous à l'aise.
Vous pouvez vaquer à d'autres occupations, l'argent va... se faire
Cette méthode est garantie à 100%. Levez-vous monsieur s'il vous plait
La chaise
Qu'es-ce qui se passe ?
Faite moi confiance, cette méthode marche à 100%. Elle est vraiment garantie
Le computer à pomme
Des centaines de personnes l'ont déjà adopté et en sont très heureux
On le prend ça ?
Ah non non pas Sergi.
Oui.
Faite moi confiance
Mon nom est Stéphane
Le "caméroscope"
Ah non pas la caméra
Bah si
Attendez juste un truc, vous voulez vraiment gagnez de l'argent
Je vais vous donnez une technique vraiment simple et infaillible
Il vous suffit d'allez au pôle emploi et de travailler
Ça c'est une technique qui marche bien ça
L'arbre
Faite moi confiance je m'appelle Stéphane
Abonnez vous à ma chaine Youtube